[Music]
hey you guys happy sunday here we are
again yeah
dj maniac and
um and elsa elsa they met uh starting
night last night they sent me some
photos
let me see if i can put a picture up
the uh starry night did a show in new
york last night
um
they were telling me about that what
they were excited about doing that show
when we first saw when we saw them just
um
a couple days back a couple uh wax
couple weeks ago we saw him that was
yeah that was beginning of october
absolution yeah there's dj maniac ilsa
and michael from a starry night
yeah elsa said it was so great i got
home at seven a.m holy [ __ ] that was a
good night
uh yeah she said i think we met them all
i got a shirt yeah yeah howard's the
guitar player he writes all the music
he's the [ __ ] genius
yeah he just i want a classic late 80s
style song you know it's going to be and
he'll [ __ ] just the riffs the sound
the
you know he can he he knows all the
sounds that how something should sound
he does it he he's he knows it backwards
and forwards he's real good he's really
into horror movies yeah real horror
movies like real uh like kind of obscure
horror movies that's what i always end
up talking about
but you can name a pretty obscure band
from our times when we were a kid and he
knows all the songs on the album
everything yep
he's one of those kind of guys
one of those kind of guys yeah yeah
they're all really nice i would say i
mean they're also an awesome band but
they're all just like really they're
really nice guys yeah so i'm gonna go
ahead and give a shout out to a starry
night and um
it's it's called a-s-t-a-r-i-n-i-t-e
uh they're all their stuff's here on
youtube
and uh really good albums it's kind of
bad you just listen to a whole whole
damn album in your car or cd in your car
and they're kind of addictive
each one of them each album got better
and better as they went oh yeah
definitely yeah i mean they're all good
but yeah they're all good but they got
better as they went
yeah sometimes that's the other way
around they get worse isn't it
star he got better as it went yeah elsa
said yeah they were so nice yeah they're
really really good yeah they're really
nice guys too yeah
so all right so let's talk about this
movie now this is uh this is interesting
because how
we got on this whole kick and it's and
it's definitely a kick because we're
doing two more like tomorrow and the day
after
uh of these kind of similar 70s
thrillers type thing
we were doing i guess when we were doing
the review of the believers right from
1987 and i mentioned that it had been
directed by john schlesinger
who had also done marathon man and then
you were kind of like oh yeah marathon
man we need to totally see that and then
rob levinson friend of the show sent us
a dvd or blu-ray of a dvd a dvd of it
yeah and so we said we would do a
matinee which i think we talked about it
a little bit on the sidetrack show but i
said well we'll kind of save it
so we can kind of just
kind of concentrate more on that like
yeah you know what i mean a lot of these
old 70s flicks if it's not totally
remastered and redone for blu-ray it
doesn't matter usually the dvd is
about as good a quality as you want if
the quality gets any better or the
resolution gets any higher the movie
starts to suffer actually because
they weren't filmed for real high
resolution
and this isn't really the kind of movie
movie yeah this is like a thriller kind
of thing so it's not like a thing where
it has these big sweeping vistas of
landscapes and [ __ ] like that it's that
kind of not that kind of thing it's a
great movie it holds up
it really does i hadn't seen it for ages
and honestly
and i think this is true of most people
that probably haven't seen it for a long
time pretty much the only scene like
most people remember
is the dentist torture scene yeah the is
it safe scene yeah it's just safe
and that even like keeps coming up that
comes up on like scariest movie scenes
and all this other kind of stuff
and i had kind of forgot i kind of
remembered like what this movie was
about it's probably been 25 years at
least since i've seen it um
but i had forgotten like a lot of the
little nuances and i'd also forgotten
how [ __ ] star studded this [ __ ]
all-star camera man everybody's done
this [ __ ] yeah uh
i forgot that um the brother with the
who was played by roy schweinsteiger
yeah i forgot that he
was kind of like the main character for
half the damn movie he was kind of like
he's a major character yeah he he's
doesn't work for the cia he works for a
a company that the cia uses and other
company fbi uses them too they're
they're contractors
uh they just called it what they call it
the company right and they called the
company working for the company
or they just yeah they just had kind of
like a generic name for it
and um
the edit is a little strange especially
the first 20 minutes it's hard to kind
of follow exactly what had happened some
kind of secret mission happened and i
don't think i totally understand exactly
what happened the dude who got blown up
with the box of chocolates in the
antique shop i don't really know how
that was related it was related
to um
to uh what was that what's the main bad
guy's name again uh the nazi guy zell
zell yeah
christian zell was his name it was
related to zell and sir lawrence olivier
yeah which is they thought this was
gonna be his last movie because he was
like on his deathbed but he did so with
this movie he lived for now he said [ __ ]
it i'm gonna live another 13 years yeah
because i was like he was in clash of
the titans like several years after this
like in 1981 he played zeus and he
looked all right in that one we watched
the extras at the end of it you know and
dustin hoffman was talking about it he
said that he was
dustin [ __ ] kind of you know based on
what he said he believes what i believe
that your mentality has a lot to do with
your health and evidently he was
his health was getting bad he had cancer
and all kinds of stuff and because he
was
down in the dumps he was dying but
because of the success of this movie
it reinvigorated him he lived for
another 13 years
yeah because i mean um lawrence olivier
was their first choice uh that's who
they wanted everybody was the first
choice yeah and they were talking about
like the producers and stuff were like
that never happens i mean obviously uh
but this is like everybody that was the
first choice we got everybody we wanted
but what ended up happening with
lawrence olivier they wanted him and he
said he would do it but then he got
really sick and then they were afraid
that he wouldn't be able to do it so i
think for a little while they thought
they had uh richard winmark come in and
he was going to do it um but then
laurence olivier got better and so they
actually were able to get him and like
you said they thought he was on his
deathbed but then he ended up living
what another 13 years 13 years and he
was in a bunch of other movies like
after that too and he had a lot of
problems cancer all kinds of problems
with his joints and i think he said
varicose veins real bad varicose veins
that's what it was yeah i think you can
barely walk
uh but he uh
really pulled it out playing zell in
this who's just uh
a great character
um they made sure to and you know they
were
talking you know when they were
discussing how they were going to do
this they didn't want zelle
to be a stereotypical cartoon type
villain you know just with the the nazi
branding on him you know what i mean he
was actually a complicated character
he wasn't really a nazi
because he had betrayed a bunch of nazis
he was in the rat line he was an ex-nazi
but he didn't believe in any of that it
was just all about power and money
well he just wanted the diamonds i mean
this whole thing like i said the whole
thing revolves around
a cache of diamonds that was stolen from
the jews during the holocaust that um
that actually christian zell and i guess
his brother who gets killed
near the beginning like in that road
rage type situation yeah that's right um
that's kind of like the impetus for zell
coming to the u.s because he had been
hiding out in south america
yeah and so that's kind of how that one
thing though okay so like this the plot
is really complicated what you were
saying
about the edit at the beginning
um
yeah you do really kind of have to pay
attention because it jumps back and
forth
in location without telling you yeah
that it's going it's like obviously like
a lot of it's in new york you have this
scene where uh the brother of christian
zell
um gets in this road rage type of thing
with this other guy yeah this other old
guy yeah it was actually a pretty good
scene that
just kind of showed i guess you could
say just like the ethnic warfare between
these two factions that were fighting
back in the honky motherland and they're
continuing to fight here in new york
and they kill each other that's that was
a [ __ ] quite a twist they both died
in that
they were one guy was calling him a nazi
other guys calling him a jew and they
[ __ ] boom and kill each other and
that's that's kind of what they ran into
a fuel truck yeah it ran into a fuel
truck
yeah and that's what called zell
and zell into the united states
yeah but um the uh dustin hoffman his
character's brother who was working for
the company he said that we don't know
what the problem with zell was remember
that he says he he was not a threat they
said he had been given up other nazis
for decades he was worked for them off
and on remember yeah well because um doc
which is roy scheider's uh character's
name who's dustin hoffman's brother in
the movie like his older brother there's
this whole thing where doc and that
other guy uh jane janey or janeway
whatever they call him that's bill
devane yeah plays him and uh they are
essentially couriers they're trading
favors
because
zell
um gives them the name of the names of
other like war criminals like nazi
escape nazis and stuff yeah in
in exchange for having the diamonds like
brought to him
so
and remember he's basically they let it
know they let you know that like i said
he's not a he's not a
a cartoon
nazi villain he didn't give a [ __ ] about
nazis he was turning them in too he and
evidently it was like that back
when he when when the nazis were around
during the war he it was just a means of
getting money in power well yeah he was
just very mercenary he was all about
himself yeah he was just very mercenary
and um
the the
cia contractors went to him they used
used him a lot
and uh he had special skills
and he didn't consider himself to be a
bad guy in the way that you would he
considered himself to be this just
artistic genius who was a dentist and
good taste and they make sure that
you know that he thinks that about
himself in the movie looking dustin
hoffman was talking about it in the
extras
that uh you know he's torturing you but
he thinks it's great this is just part
of his job well dustin hoffman in the
extras he relates this thing he's like
before like they were gonna shoot the
very famous torture scene where he's in
there drilling into his teeth trying to
get information out of dustin hoffman's
character
and uh i guess they had been like
thinking about it for a while and
laurence olivier wasn't sure how he was
going to play it
and the story goes that laurence olivier
saw like outside the hotel or wherever
he was staying or whatever and he saw
this guy like a gardener and he was like
trimming roses and he said this guy was
just you could tell that he was just so
careful and like so meticulous and he
was just like so into his job and like
into these roses and everything and he's
like and he and he kind of had this
revelation that he's like that's how i'm
going to play that scene where it's it's
almost kind of like he's taking a lot of
pride in his work like torturing this
poor guy well i like
i like that touch because in real good
stories
the villain
never sees himself as a villain really
he well that's kind of true of most
villains it's at least good ones like
yeah that's just the way the world is
everybody can see themselves as the good
guy yeah i mean well like i said and uh
dave conte says the fact that he was
recognized near the end of the movie by
a holocaust survivor actually two of
them uh tells you that he wasn't just
some mercenary guy he was later yeah um
he did actually work in the camps you
know and they and he was infamous at the
camps as being a torturer because they
had a name for him yeah the white angel
yeah the white so he's kind of based on
joseph mengele joseph that's well that's
what i was saying
the same thing they found mangala's body
i think during the time that my mother
was stationed in uh
in brazil
and that dude was another one that was
just a mercenary megalo didn't give a
[ __ ] about any of that he didn't he
wasn't a real nazi per se he was in
there to make money and uh and to have
ex
because
people forget that they were in there
doing medical research and they were
doing it for [ __ ]
big drug companies some of them ties to
america and they were just making a lot
of money on stuff and
when they found mangala's body they did
an investigation he was basically
married to a black woman brazil it's a
it was just
those dudes just
most a lot of those guys were not true
believers in any of that that was like
they just saw opportunities and took
them
well and they were just and they didn't
give a [ __ ] no i mean if they had to
torture people or they're just kind of
cold-blooded they didn't give a [ __ ]
about those people yeah it's like that
damn experiment where they're getting
people to shock other people if you've
got a government above you telling you
that hey it's okay to kill these people
we say it's okay then okay there's a lot
of people that go along with it oh okay
how much you gonna pay me all right fine
and there's a lot of psychopaths like
that a lot of normal people will do it
that milgram experiments that was called
yeah the milgram experiment yeah they
were
doing in a lab coat was just telling
some dudes to shock somebody else they
couldn't see them and they'd go along
with it because it was an authority
figure tower to do it
i don't think it was the majority i
think about half people
well half didn't get like went partially
partially and then they were like nah
i'm not doing this anymore
anybody having to do with those camps
not only in germany but the camps in
japan too that they were doing it
actually the japanese camps in china
they were [ __ ] psychos they were
psychos
only a psycho could do that they were
kind of selected for that yeah you know
a
a normal person would couldn't do that
that's not who they were looking for
yeah they knew they did psychologically
value evaluations on guys and they were
looking right for the high functioning
psychopaths who had the skills and they
were sent there to do those jobs
imagine that
but yeah so what i was saying earlier
about like the first part of the movie
so you know it starts in new york with
that whole like thing which is kind of
like not
i want to say that that's not um
it's not like really important to the
plot it's the thing that sets the plot
into motion you know what i mean the the
two cars like hitting the
you know hitting the truck or whatever
that sets the plot into motion
but um you know so it jumps like from
new york and they kind of like follow
dustin hoffman's character his name is
babe levy
um and they kind of go a little bit into
his backstory like about he's a phd
student he's like he's studying history
and he's studying like uh tyranny like
throughout history uh and they kind of
go into the backstory about like his dad
who i guess was investigated during the
mccarthy era and ended up shooting
himself so there's that whole thing and
then he kind of like talks a little bit
about his brother who
and then it jumps over to paris but it's
not telling you that it's paris yet it's
just kind of like jumping over there and
that's where doc roy schneider's
character is
yeah and there's like some sketchy [ __ ]
like i said
you really kind of have to be paying
attention because i probably should have
put the um
the woody column the closed captioning
on because a lot of the times because
i'm deaf as [ __ ] and i can't hear like a
lot of dialogue and if i can't hear the
dialogue then
i don't have any like idea what's going
on but
after i went like after i watched it
like i went back because i figured it
out later but then like i went back and
like read through the plot i was just
kind of like oh okay now it makes sense
they don't say much in the beginning
yeah they don't really say much and like
i said it kind of jumps from location to
location and you're not entirely sure
like you have to kind of be patient with
it because you're like well how are all
these threads how do all these threads
like tie together but then like i said
you you have to kind of like just wait
because it does all come together in the
end it's just that at first it seems
like it's kind of like jumping around
and you're like okay well i don't know
how this has to do with that one thing
that's still confusing and if you guys
have seen this movie please tell me
so at the beginning part before doc
comes to new york like when he's still
in paris
and he goes to the antique shop right
and he talks to that guy like the owner
of the antique shop and they talk about
something or other now
forgive me if i'm wrong but before he
goes to visit that guy
roy scheider goes to like a chocolate
shop and he buys like a box of
chocolates
and then he goes back to his hotel room
and dumps those chocolates out and puts
in another one
that looks like the same thing
and then he takes him to that guy and i
say did he just poison that guy
but then like something blows up but
then like later on he's supposed to meet
that guy at the theater and when he gets
to the theater the guy's there but his
throat is cut
so i'm like wait a minute well then what
like because i thought that he was like
who did he kill then right like i did
like i did that and i looked on the
wikipedia thing and i was just kind of
like it was vague there too yeah it was
kind and well it didn't even mention it
and so i was just kind of like well why
why the switching chocolates because i
kind of i mean the first thing i thought
oh he's gonna poison that dude
but that wasn't what it was but then
like something blew up but then was the
bomb intended for doc
because because he kind of came out of
the car and he's like oh [ __ ] you know
what i mean like so he didn't know that
it was and then but like i said i
thought oh he blew up the the french guy
but then later he goes to meet him at
the opera house maybe maybe and the dude
was up in the box and his throat was cut
like somebody else had got to him first
maybe the chocolates were explosive
and they blew up but it didn't kill him
it wasn't maybe he intended to kill him
but it didn't i don't know
yeah but then if he had intended to kill
him then why would he go to the theater
later to meet him see that's that didn't
make any sense
but see what was going on was missing
yeah what was going on was that doc
as well as uh janie that other guy and
presumably the french guy those were all
uh couriers for zell
yeah so what they would do was they
would go back and forth and they would
go and get his cash of diamonds and like
bring it to him in exchange for
information about other war criminals
so what ended up happening was that
after
zell's brother died in new york he
decided well i'm not gonna [ __ ] with all
these couriers anymore because i guess
even though his brother dying was like
an accident essentially it didn't have
anything to do with what's going on
but i guess he thought
oh well somebody killed my brother so
they're turning on me so i'm gonna wipe
out all of my couriers so that's why
like somebody came in doc's room and
like tried to kill him that's why that
guy like with the white eyes was trying
to kill doc in paris and stuff like that
because zell was trying to wipe out all
of the couriers
like because he thought that they were
targeting him because his brother died i
don't think he he got that like his
brother's death didn't have anything to
do with the plot you know what i mean or
what was going on but i'm still like
confused about that thing in france i
don't know what happened there yeah dave
i read your comment now just because if
you go back in history and look at the
actual players that did that [ __ ] a lot
of that [ __ ] they weren't true believers
they just did it because there was money
and they were told them to do it
but then like what
this is accurate then they'd go on the
run in the in the rat line and they turn
up they they
they would you know talk [ __ ] about
the the third reich and [ __ ] turn
dudes in and oh they're like yeah it was
all [ __ ] i just wanted the money and
the power or whatever and
um they didn't believe in any of that
they just did it because they were
criminals
that's a lot of a lot of it was that and
you could uh get them to roll on each
other a lot which that's what zell was
doing because they didn't care they only
cared about themselves they were psychos
yeah and another thing too is that
interestingly dustin hoffman's character
um
he actually initially had nothing to do
with all of this plot that was going on
and had no idea
what any of this stuff was because he
thought doc's cover story his brother's
cover story was that he worked as an oil
company executive and that is what um
that's what dustin hoffman thought that
he that his brother did that but then
when the brother came there
and you know the brother ends up getting
killed and then uh for whatever reason
like zell thinks that the brother knows
some information even though he doesn't
it doesn't have anything to do with it
um that's when he starts torturing like
to try to get information and that's
kind of when
all the other guys like you know the
guys that had been doing stuff for zelle
or working with like for through the cia
or contract or whatever they were doing
um that's when they started because
janie that one guy the guy that bill
devane plays he's kind of like a double
agent he's kind of like working both
sides you know what i mean because he
initially like tried to help
justin hoffman like you know trying to
get him away from zell but then he's
like no no never mind and he like takes
him back because they thought that he
knew something like some kind of
valuable information yeah the good thing
another thing i liked about it is this
in some ways the movie is kind of like
along the same vein as three days the
condor it just shows all these guys that
are in this what they call intelligence
community which they kind of scoff at
that in three days of the condo that
that [ __ ] they betray each other all
the time
pat hatfield asks i'd also like to know
if this is based on a book yes it is
it's based on the book by william
goldman who has written [ __ ] tons of
books and uh screenplays and [ __ ] like
that he's got a couple oscars he wrote
all the president's men he wrote the
princess bride he wrote tons and tons of
different stuff
actually like before this book was even
published uh the producers bought the
rights to it for like half a mil because
they said it's very very rare like even
the guy that bought the rights was like
this is the best [ __ ] i've read since
the godfather he's like this almost
reads like a movie already and he's like
and we can't lose if we don't [ __ ] it up
so it was so um yeah so the book riots
were bought before the book even was
published now william goldman also wrote
the screenplay
however
they changed the ending from the book
there's a couple different things in the
book in the book
um
one thing that's in the book that i
think they only very very briefly kind
of imply in the movie is that doc and
janie janeway are gay lovers okay that's
in the book that's not really in the
movie i think there's one like kind of
throwaway line that you could kind of
read like that but they took that out of
the movie
um the ending is also different
in the ending of the book
uh it kind of ends the same where you
know they they give babe dustin
hoffman's character they give him the
information where zell is because babe
says i'm going to go kill the
[ __ ] and in the book in the book
he actually just does go and just like
kills the dude in cold blood right
um in the movie dustin hoffman didn't
really want to do that like he didn't
want it to end that way and he kind of
explained like why he didn't want like
on the extras they interviewed him
extensively about it
and i think what he was getting at was
that he didn't want his character to be
seen as like the same as that guy like
he wanted to see like be the better man
or whatever yeah so i mean he does end
up like the nazi does end up dying but
he doesn't end up like straight up
killing him although he does plan to
he's going to yeah zell actually kills
himself by accident yeah that's what
that's what happens yeah and uh william
goldman famously really did not like
that ending he called it [ __ ]
quote-unquote
[Laughter]
but um i don't know i can see either way
i can see either way like i i couldn't
understand why dustin hoffman just
thought he didn't want moral equivalency
yeah he didn't want he's like you know
my character i want him to even though i
he does say in the movie that i want to
kill that [ __ ] and he takes the
information and everything and he does
intend to but then when he's right in
front of his face he can't really bring
himself to do it and like i said i guess
that's why because he's just like well i
don't want to be the same as that guy so
i get that i get why he didn't want to
do that but um what killing a
cold-blooded killer in cold blood makes
you a cold-blooded killer yeah so i can
totally see what he's talking about i
mean even though like from a point of
view of like the book you'd be like yeah
kill that [ __ ] but you know what i
mean but i can see how in the movie it
would have
it makes the it makes it less
complicated and it makes him like a less
uh sympathetic character i guess yeah
even though i don't know well i think i
think i think uh dustin hoffman wanted
the character to be kind of like a
an example of better morality yeah yeah
yes
did not moral equivalency
but like i said the author of the book
says he has a [ __ ] because that's that's
more like the way the world really is
yeah but like i said you know movies in
real life aren't really the same thing
right um but i but i can see i can
there's arguments for both sides i don't
really have a problem with either ending
uh so so i'm not really bothered now
interestingly and here's something that
uh was also on the wikipedia page and i
think this is kind of like a famous
story about the making of this movie
uh which i'm not sure is entirely i'm
not saying it's not true i'm just saying
that it's kind of like mis
perceived a little bit
i think that there was um
there's kind of a
perception that dustin hoffman and
lawrence olivier didn't get along when
they were making this movie mainly
because lawrence olivier was very
old-school hollywood very theatrical you
know he had a shakespearean background
yada yada obviously and dustin hoffman
even though he was almost 40 when this
movie was made which blew our minds
i was just sitting there because he's
playing well he's playing a grad student
in the movie and he said when he was
asked to do the movie that he even
thought it was weird he's like aren't
you aren't i a little old for this role
but it worked because he he doesn't come
across as somebody that's 40 years old
you know what i mean um so i was
actually surprised when he said yeah i
was almost 40 when we made this movie
and i thought i was too old for it but
it worked out because he doesn't come
across like that
but he was kind of like more
even though he was almost 40 he was
almost like a younger hollywood type
thing so he's kind of like
a very instinctual kind of actor and has
like a little bit of a method acting
kind of thing where
uh and there's a very famous story about
this uh very famous anecdote about this
movie where they're like you know in one
part of the movie he had to have been
like his character had to have been like
awake for three days or like hadn't
eaten and stuff so dustin hoffman's like
so i just stayed up for three days and
didn't eat you know what i mean and then
laurence olivier very famously said to
him it's like why don't you try acting
but
like instead of actually doing it
but um actually dustin hoffman he talked
about that a great deal and he was like
i wanted to clarify he's like he did say
that
but they're like you're kind of missing
like all of the context of he's like he
didn't mean it like
you know oh you lame ass like you can't
even act like you have to do it for real
it's like he didn't mean it like that
like he kind of clarified what he meant
after that and honestly like all the
behind the scenes stuff they look like
they got along really well and dustin
hoffman said after the movie wrapped
um lawrence olivier came to his house
and brought him this big box of all of
his uh you know the shakespeare plays
and like the books and stuff that he'd
been in that he had all his acting notes
like wrote in there and he gave them
like to dustin hoffman as a present and
even even this many years later like
dustin hoffman's kind of tearing up like
talking about it he's like and he said
made a joke about how i think i want to
be buried with these because it's like
one of the most awesome things i ever
got so
it did really kind of seem like they got
yes their their styles were very
different but i think that it's kind of
been overblown like how they didn't get
along on set and [ __ ] like that hoffman
was really uh
one of the best actors in hollywood in
modern hollywood he was good he could
pull off some ass rolls
and he wasn't a man for any old role
but if you had a crazy ass role
like tootsie or rain man
he would go all out to try to bring that
that role to the to the big screen now
as as his career went on you know the mu
the movies started to suffer that really
wasn't him it was just casting i think
he was doing something about pandemics
that weren't all that great and uh oh
yeah what was that yeah
i can't remember what that was just i
know what you're talking he just stopped
offering him choice [ __ ] he was starting
to age out he was much older than you
thought he was when you looked at him
yeah because like i said i was like
really he was almost 40 in 1976 holy
crap yeah i didn't realize i guess i
just thought yeah so he just kind of
didn't look he wasn't getting choice
rolls so he just retired which is what
that's what you do
well he had an outbreak that was the
yeah
yeah i remember that being okay
i remember that being okay anybody could
have done that role though that's true
you didn't need dustin offer for that
that was just paycheck
yeah and like i said i don't you know i
i don't [ __ ] on actors like once they
get older like [ __ ] gets tough out there
man it's like everybody wants like the
newest hottest thing it's like once you
get into your 40s and 50s everybody's
like yeah
they're just you know you're gonna end
up on like [ __ ] lifetime christmas
movies and [ __ ] like that if you're not
careful
so you know unless you're
you know and i'm not saying there are
like obviously some older actors that
you know still get a lot of like really
prestigious work and everything like
that but in general i remember one time
where he said he wanted to play james
bond imagine that
really yeah long time ago i think it was
him that said that i don't know i don't
know if that would work yeah he wanted
to be james bond but he's not he's not
british though no he could fake it he
could be at me he could fake it
although honestly i've i i've i can't
really think of any i'm sure someone
will think of something but i can't
really think of an american actor that
has very convincingly played a british
person
the accent is never exactly right yeah
i've seen a lot of british actors that
can play americans that i didn't realize
that they were not americans yeah um but
i've been walking dead
yeah i've never seen the reverse though
over time i was able to go yeah he is a
little he is kind of hamming it up a
little bit with the word with carl the
word you know
well the thing though is that it did
sound if you didn't know that he was
british yeah which we didn't when i was
because i hadn't seen love actually at
that point because he was also in love
actually like before that which is like
a british movie um so i didn't realize
that andrew lincoln was british yeah uh
so
i didn't question it you know what i
mean it didn't sound weird to me or
anything like that but like i said it's
really hard
it was supposed to be mississippi
alabama around that time and uh if you
listen the difference between him and
say uh
who's the other guy uh guy who's really
from mississippi [ __ ]
guy who played merle
um
um [ __ ]
[ __ ] michael rooker michael rooker yeah
you can you can
it reminds me of how different it
actually is
you know it
michael rooker actually has the real
accent well yeah because he's actually
from yeah he's actually from mississippi
but like i said i mean the one andrew
lincoln did was
it almost sounded something like
virginia though and honestly if you if
you just went up to him and he was
talking like that i wouldn't question it
i wouldn't be like are you a british
person masquerading as it no no that
would never occur to me it's just that
it it wasn't quite alabama mississippi
more like virginia
tennes yeah it's kind of it was it's a
little bit different maybe texas
something like that roy says there was a
lot of films to do with whatever
happened to the nazis after the war type
of films yeah there were like
particularly around that era well it was
just ripe for books and spy novels it
was a great you know i mean they didn't
think they didn't get them all a lot of
them [ __ ] yeah so that's right for
fiction right and non-fiction too uh
love dustin hoffman the graduate we need
to get around to doing that one of these
days because i really liked it i watched
midnight cowboy last night it's a great
movie
we'll probably do that one tuesday
because we did it we watched another one
like that we weren't gonna do in between
the more i thought about it the more i
realized how deep that movie was the
movie was very deep a lot of symbolism
in it
yeah
uh and then
psychology and [ __ ] yeah we're also
bringing up uh straw dogs which was also
a fantastic movie which is another one
that we haven't done god there's so many
that we haven't yeah grandfather's
hammer's talking about dustin hoffman
ended up in the meet the fockers
franchise i you know what i have not
seen a single one of those and i just
feel like i probably never will and i'm
i'm happy with my decision
[Laughter]
sheila anne says he was self-conscious
of his looks
yeah yeah
i mean i guess graham got about boys
from brazil that was another good movie
yeah yeah we need to see that one again
too granthar's hammer said renee
zellweger played british bridget jones i
saw that but i still
i j i think her accent wasn't that good
it wasn't the worst
but she did not sound like a british
person to me
it was okay
but i still knew that that was not what
she really talked like
uh camp guys said british folks are much
better at doing accents yeah i agree no
that's not what really what it is what
it is is that british actors actually
come from the theater from a very good
training programs american actors don't
american actors
typically came from the hollywood scene
which was mostly happening in nightclubs
and uh cocaine fueled [ __ ] orgies
again you got the part what you know
depending on [ __ ] who you put out to
and [ __ ] how much coke you're willing
to advance [ __ ] like that because
hollywood was corrupt it was a party
scene they take it seriously it was just
movies
you know yeah hoffman was the [ __ ]
actually he could act a lot of there
were a lot of them in the 70s that could
act but they a lot of them didn't really
survive the 80s too well they slowly
started to drop off
and uh
well and that is [ __ ] cheap well the
thing about the late 60s and early 70s
was kind of like an auteur
decade where people were kind of willing
to watch these sort of boundary crossing
movies you know more art films stuff
like that that so i kind of feel like
there was more
opportunity if you were a really good
actor to get into something like really
critically acclaimed and stuff like that
whereas when the 80s came along
everything was just kind of like cheap
schlock or
or big like blockbusters yeah so if you
weren't if you were just kind of like
this actor
then you know there was still like a lot
of indie movies in the 80s obviously but
it wasn't as
i don't know i just feel like in the 70s
was kind of like the heyday of
a lot of this a lot of the best american
movies especially sci-fi and action type
movies from the late 70s and into the
80s
they're
movies that on a surface you say yeah
it's an american movie but if you look
at the details man they were british
like alien 2 was a british movie
aliens might have been british that
might have been done at those studios
there what the first ailment the first
one oh i can't i can't remember i don't
think that was american a lot of that
stuff
was not technically not american you had
to go to the uh you had to go to england
to get a lot of that [ __ ] done because
those studios had real professional
casts that [ __ ] worked well and uh
knew how things should look
you'd end up with something that was
kind of aged and worn it would look
realistic you know like the star wars
used universe you know that that's
british did that [ __ ]
hate to say it well probably the
americans wouldn't even have thought of
that
american sci-fi they should look brand
spanking new everything's shiny
yeah
yeah it just wasn't really well thought
out and it would have cost a lot more in
the united states because of all the
palms you'd have to grease and the
corruption and
the scheduling wouldn't have worked and
when they made you know when lucas made
the first star wars he didn't really
know what he was doing either you know
like and it was going way
farther way behind schedule because
they said it wasn't being run like a
real even though it was in one of those
british studios his directing style was
just
like something some some kid from school
would do there's just bad [ __ ]
scheduling and [ __ ] bad discipline on
the set and
lucas was kind of a failure his first
couple movies it took him i think it
took him a while to i think steven
spielberg whipped him into shape
i think steven spielberg is one yeah
probably taught him how to [ __ ] make
a movie
in a in a timely fashion yeah quit
[ __ ] around george yeah
george was a great idea man though oh
yeah
but like i said not everybody's good at
everything yeah you know you can be like
completely brilliant at one thing and
like suck at everything else it's like
you know that's just the way the [ __ ]
rolls my favorite movie of his you know
was actually thx 1138 i think that was
his best movie that's a that's a pretty
fantastic yeah they've said have we done
that but we've we've done it right i
don't think so i don't think we've done
it i thought we'd done it there's two of
them one of them he did for a school and
the other one that got released to the
big screen i liked the one that was
released i thought we had it we have it
i don't have it oh [ __ ] it's been redone
and some you know he did he lucasfied it
you know what i mean it inserted some
scenes and some cg and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
they cgi'd over the little the little
dwarves the little shell dwellers they
made them look non-human because i guess
they didn't want to insult midgets or
something i don't know what it [ __ ]
was but that they should have left those
because he got that from brave new world
and in the brave new world series all
the
little d level workers and everything
were were dwarves
you know it made them small on purpose
and small with low iqs they were like
human
human robots
and
it's a dystopian future that's like some
[ __ ] that they would do
camp guy says i need to watch midnight
cowboy and dog day afternoon yeah like i
said we watched midnight cowboy last
night so we're gonna do we're not gonna
do it tomorrow we'll do it tuesday
midnight because like i said we have
another movie we're gonna do tomorrow
that we also watched midnight cowboys a
much better movie than i remember now
that i'm older seeing it i understood it
a lot better
see this is why if a movie is like a
classic and the first time you saw it
you were young or you just didn't get it
or whatever you should definitely give
it another chance
every decade of your life when you see
them
you see when you're young it's just some
crazy flick about this
dude this cowboy from texas who goes to
new york to try to pimp himself out to
old women and he and he and he makes
friends with this
dude named ratso who's just uh
exactly the opposite to him a little
ugly
[ __ ] clubfooted
[ __ ]
shell dweller in living in a damn
abandoned apartment you know what i mean
who's he's just a totally untrustworthy
con man
but there's a lot more to that movie
than that
it's it's it has to do with sexual
psychology it's not a classic for
nothing yeah i mean you know right and
then as the story unfolds they start
doing flashbacks and the flashbacks
explain why this [ __ ] dude from texas
just
why he's doing what he's doing you know
it makes sense from his point of view if
he had his background but it ends up
being resolved
save it for teamsters
yeah badass domain says you guys should
do hook with dustin hoffman williams i
you know what i haven't seen that in a
really long time i hated that movie when
i saw it really i can't i remember like
thinking ah that was all right but i
don't you know like i said it's been
such a long time i don't remember hardly
anything about it what i remember liking
better was uh robin williams popeye the
live action pop i remember i kind of
liked that too i remember liking it
it's probably terrible i don't know
crazy i remember it just being crazy
i remember liking it it's like that's i
love robin williams but i tend to like
um
i tend to like his later movies when he
was kind of more like in a series
because he could [ __ ] act you know
what i mean oh yeah he was jesus but
it's just you know a lot of times like i
think that you know it as funny as his
[ __ ] was like in the 80s
i don't know like nowadays i think i'm
too old because i'm just like oh dude
he's like so coked out can you just like
kind of like bring it down a couple
notches but um but you know so but the
cool [ __ ] was cool back then though
robin williams best movie was [ __ ]
one hour photo and that's almost like a
goddamn horror movie that was his name
you need to see insomnia yeah he played
kind of like a similar role in that as
well like kind of a scary was he a
serial killer i kind of feel like he was
a serial killer in that um
caroline dyson says we're talking about
accents david morrissey's accent as the
governor was awful on walking dead yeah
now that i'm thinking because he's a
brit too so he couldn't really do an
american one all that yeah that was a
little weird he did yeah he just sounded
a little strange uh strawdog 78 says
robert downey jr as sherlock holmes
accent was decent yeah i remember that
being passable
um granthar's hamper hammer says worst
accent in recent movie history jennifer
lawrence in red sparrow
she sounded like natasha from rocky hit
pulled winkle oh my god now i'm gonna
have to see that
ah
yeah donald pleasence was in thx uh 11
30. that's right yeah and a lot of that
shipped in tx
thx 1138 kind of came true over time
everybody being on these ssri inhibitors
and whole cultures about buying useless
things and
worshiping commerce and how it's just
[ __ ] that's a that's a that's a
badass movie i liked it they're just
people living in a fake society
uh kind of like kind of like
kind of like a
more dystopic version of logan's run
yeah
it's just a
totally drugged up society
you're
to evade drugs
was to commit a criminal offense
and
you couldn't have sex either that was
called a sex crime
and they'd [ __ ] lock you up for it
but
even the average person could escape
from that prison that was just
people were so had such dependent
personalities they stayed right where
you put them it was a weird weird movie
louie points out american graffiti is a
great movie by lucas and that was in his
film career that was pretty good too
yeah that was good too kind of a slice
of life movie
i need to see that one again too like
i've seen all of these movies but it's
like it's been so long since i've seen
them it didn't make a big impression on
me though
but it might now like i said it might
it's it might be one of those things
that like needs time to like gesture you
know what i mean because i've seen some
movies well i have the opposite thing
too where it's like movies i saw when i
was younger and i was like man this is
the most awesome thing ever but then
like later i saw and i'm just like what
the [ __ ] was i even thinking but um
but yeah then sometimes i see a movie
like a long time ago and i was just like
meh but then i see it again i'm like oh
my god that was awesome what the [ __ ]
some aged really well like close
encounters are the third kind i like
that now then i like better i liked it
more now than i did when i i did too the
first time i saw it i was just kind of
like yeah yeah i didn't really care
about it but then like when i saw it
again recently i was just kind of like
oh my god it's like i totally missed
like all of this [ __ ] that was going on
in there there's a lot of good dialogue
in it yeah it happened he's throwing the
trees into the [ __ ] into the window
of the house
[Laughter]
i love that she
[Laughter]
yeah i can't remember either yeah
serpent surfer this i this made me laugh
the carry-on series had better set
direction than most american productions
at the time i don't think how many
carry-on movies were there because
i've maybe seen one or two of them
this is like a very long-running british
film series it's always like carry on
something like carry on walking or
carrying whatever the [ __ ] and it's like
always has a word at the end and they're
just kind of like essentially farces
they're usually like sex comedy type uh
funny [ __ ] like that it's from what i
remember hollywood got better as it went
on because it had to back when they had
a monopoly over all the theaters
and uh basically you know i mean uh they
could basically get away with murder
television came in and it started to you
know hurt their profits they had to get
a little bit better had to you had to do
better than television which that that
went on for a while but now that a lot
of these series are so good and you got
silicon valley involved and making
movies and fun and [ __ ] all these
indie films that are great you know what
i mean great indie films that are
happening hollywood's playing catch-up
man you can't [ __ ] around like they did
back in the day
it's got to be
efficient you can't waste money
and how they would just waste money or
lie about how much they spent because
there was a bunch of shenanigans going
on tax evasion and [ __ ] and laundering
money through movies and
sex trade was happening through movies
and [ __ ]
just look let's look at the weinstein
thing you know what i mean
if you have the power to give a woman a
job and that job would make her a
million or two million dollars
these guys would go oh well yeah i'm
gonna give you this job
and you'll make two million dollars but
you're gonna have to blow me
oh and by the way blow him and that one
blow that one over there
and that was kind of going on all the
way back into the 20s when during the
silver screen era it's kind of where
actresses got the reputation for just
being hookers which they kind of were
and that kind of went on into the damn
fashion industry
celebrities and rich guys didn't go to
the damn escort services they went to
those modeling agencies
modeling agency was just escort service
for [ __ ] rich dudes
it's abit true
badass domain says would you guys review
convoy smokey and the bandit and the
cannonball run movies yeah we might get
around to that because honestly uh when
i was a kid i used to love smoking the
bandit and the cannonball run movies uh
this is kind of related
uh the other night i actually watched
the rifftrax version of breaker breaker
the early chuck norris film wow that
movie is painfully bad really bad yeah
but uh
super fun with the rifftrax commentary
wow what a stupid [ __ ] movie
i remember cannonball one and two i
remember them being as like
star-studded
yeah everybody was in there everybody
was in they were like laugh a minute is
the way i remembered them and they were
just kind of like
they were kind of epic in a way but they
were also like really really corny
and yeah they were supposed to be corny
it wasn't supposed to represent and then
i remember smoking the bandit being
pretty corny too but for some reason we
liked it uh you know i don't know why
there was something i guess there was
something kind of charming about it yeah
you know
well that was like fields was in it she
was cute as [ __ ] that's true that was
one thing about it i mean that's like i
said i can't comment because i probably
haven't seen it since
the late 1980s yeah that's probably like
the last time i saw any of them and i
remember really liking those and
thinking they were funny but now i just
might now i might watch it and just be
like yeah
humor doesn't age that well in general
yeah like i said it depends like
sometimes i'll see a movie like a comedy
that came out back then that's still
funny but most of the time
not so much i've tried to watch i tried
to watch history of the world part one
and that [ __ ] i just couldn't get
through it it just [ __ ] sucked i
remember thinking it was hilarious when
i was a kid
the only one that aged pretty well was
airplane
well and mel brooks movies blazing
saddles age and young frankenstein yeah
young frankenstein but i haven't seen
like the other ones like i used to
really love spaceballs but i haven't
seen that in a really long time i didn't
like it when it came out i didn't think
it was funny so i don't know if i if if
i would not think it was funny nowadays
i'm not really sure horny [ __ ]
although i imagine blazing saddles is
probably still pretty funny because
that's [ __ ] gene wilder's in that
[ __ ]
i mean how can you not love jean weather
come on
gee wow grantham's hammer says blues
brothers is still a hoot man i need to
watch that one again too
i haven't seen that one probably since
1987 or
[ __ ] something like that another one i
want to see again is stir crazy
oh yeah
yeah
uh i remember thinking it was hilarious
but
how bad could it be it's got richard
pryor and gene wilder in it it's got to
be good i mean yeah just watching the
two of them you know just farting around
is like funny yeah
like i said the best thing about i think
i talked about this when we talked about
young frankenstein
gene wilder
is just kind of he's just one of those
dudes that's just funny it just seems
like effortless like even he's not
telling a joke or nothing like that it's
just like funny it's his facial
expressions i guess
and he kind of had his [ __ ] soft
voice and he would say
but you also had the impression that he
might just like flip out it like anybody
and he was constantly seemed to be on
the verge of busting up
and breaking character and
you know he's trying to keep it together
and it's making you laugh because you
can see that he's getting ready to
[ __ ] lose it sometimes
[Music]
oh my god yeah although i will say that
in uh in uh what do you call it the
willy wonka the chocolate factory
that scene at the end when i was a kid
that scene at the end where he yells at
charlie yeah wrong sir wrong like that
used to like scare the [ __ ] out of me
because because he'd been so nice and
like he's kind of a little bit sinister
but then like when he flips out at the
end i was like
like when i was a little kid i was like
he was so nice now he's yelling at me oh
my god but yeah so he was like [ __ ]
genius at those type of roles louis says
cannonball run dean martin and sammy
davis jr as a priest yeah that i
remember that being like really funny i
remember the two of them and i remember
like the two hot chicks and the shiny
uh zippered like uh whatever you call
what do you call them
uh
jumpsuits there you go if you look
closely at sammy davis jr he's actually
dressed as a satanic priest he is he's
wearing a head of baphomet [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and it's the necklace that anton levay
gave you yeah
i don't know that but anton levay gave
him a [ __ ] necklace and made him like
a bishop of the satanic church
which how [ __ ] rad is that i mean
come on yeah which wasn't it's an
honorary title it's just yeah he's like
i don't think i don't have to do
anything i don't want to go to the
meeting they you know evidently they met
and
was impressed with his singing and
dancing and just thought he was the
greatest so he just gave him a necklace
and made him a [ __ ] bishop i think
well thank you very much
[Laughter]
but he thought it was he thought it was
he thought it was a [ __ ] trip so he
wore it in cannonball run
krampur's hammer said i was mike tv in a
local production of charlie and the
chocolate factory when i was 12. mary
lynn ricegum was an oompa loompa really
yeah
is that true
that was before i knew her was she like
the head oompa loompa
was there even a head in bloomberg not
really
they were all kind of they were all
about sex it was it was all democratized
oh my goodness
all right are we done talking yeah all
right so yeah so again thank you rob for
sending us marathon man uh like i said
the dvd is good it's got two it's got
like a behind the scenes thing from like
the time period or like the 70s and then
it has one from i don't know how old the
the other interview that they have is
but it was like it was after laurence
olivier died but they you know dustin
hoffman looks
still he looks old but like fairly young
so i don't know maybe it was from like
the early 2000s or something like that
but yeah it's a it's an awesome movie
really good 70s thriller if anybody's
read the book uh let me know if that's
any good because like i said i've heard
it was a lot different i've read some of
william goldman's stuff but not that one
oh uh let me tell him we also because
you guys might want to watch it before
you you uh see the show we saw capricorn
one yeah we're gonna talk about
capricorn one tomorrow it's free on
amazon
amazon prime and it's a good one you
gotta check it out i had forgotten how
good that movie is yeah it's super fun a
lot of [ __ ] twists through me it's
not about faking the moonland and it's
about faking the mars landing but that's
just the beginning same god same yeah
but yeah so we watched so that's the one
we're going to talk about tomorrow and
then we'll do midnight cowboy on tuesday
yeah because those are the ones that
we've been watching over this weekend
all right so thanks everybody for
dropping by and we will see you guys
again tomorrow